احنا هنا موجودين بالنسبه لارجيل المعبر
الحدودي ما بين مصر والسودان وصلنا حاله
الوفاه اللي فوق ال15 يعني لا تقل عن
اسبوع واحد
[موسيقى]
الحراره هنا بتعلى عن كده ساعات بتوصل
حاجه وخمسين في ناس معنا عندها السكر
عندها الضغط الوضع الحراره هنا كل يوم
اسوا من التاني احنا مش طالبين حاجه يعني
خارجه عن الاراده اللي احنا طالبينه ان حد
ينظر لنا بعين الرحمه في ناس هنا ميه
الشرب خلصت منها ده السكر خلص منه
[موسيقى]
مسامحينه يا عم الحاج سامحينه ربنا يرحمهم
ويغفر لهم يا رب ويصبر اهاليهم يجوا
السواقين ماتوا في الحظيره بتاعه العفش في
حلفا دول مش هيعرفوا ينزلوا مصر عشان
جثثهم متحللت من درجه الحراره وفي غيرهم
كل يوم سواقين بتموت
[موسيقى]
للمعبران المصري
العجل
واقفته
في سبيل الله
منهم من يموت
[موسيقى]
الناس دي مرميه يا جماعه زي ما انتم
شايفين كده
[موسيقى]
كل طالبينه عايزين نروح لعيالنا سالمين
غانمين مشوا لنا الدنيا شافونا العطله
منين احنا مش طالبين معجزه ده طالبين حد
ينظر لنا بعين الرحمه والله العظيم هنا
بنموت